Bây giờ bao nhiêu đứt sống ngày 20, thành sấu theo dợi Tây Heron.
Mày hoai tạc cứ tạng hình bây hai của khu quân quân quân quân quân quân quân quân hồi man.
Bình đổi với qua đại tây dân và đi ở Trung Hải,
hình hình hình hương mề mồn yên tí lo mẹ,
với các lần tiếp nhìn liệu trên không,
tại những điểm chính lợp tá được trình bị ử trước.
Đến khổ khu dở 8,5, giả sáng ngày 20, 2,5, các tiêm biết hộ tống từ lực lực lực động mình ra nhập cộ hiền.
Tạo nên một biến đổi bỗng hợp 8 xa khu vật iran.
Một giờ 8 mi khu, và một ít dội Mỹ sâm nhập khu vật iran trong tình trạng thàn hình gần đối,
vượt qua các hiện hưởng ra đà phòng không kiến tiêm nhất.
Trong khoảng thời gian từ 2 giờ 1,5 đến 2 giờ 8 mi,
bây bỏi tạc cơ vê hai đồng loạn khai hoạc, tấn công 3 buộc yêu chính lượng.
Cơ sở hạm nhân khu đồ, tổ hợp làm sấu udan yung tại Natans.
Căn cứu quân sự is phà hàn, các cuộc tấn công lực thực hiện với độ chỉ sắc gần như kiện đối,
với thiện hạm nhân trọng cho năng lực không tụ và chính chính hạm nhân của iran.
Sau khi hạm tất nhiệm vụ, đêm đối với các cơ hên trong suốt khỏi khu vật iran và trở về an quan.
Đánh giấu một trong những chính dịch không thích đầm xa chính xác và tạo bạo nhất trong lực sự diện đại.